hey it's Camilla Harris she's a rising
star in the Democratic Party the most
sort of Obama like height around her
[Applause]
last week senator Kamala Harris finally
made it official I am running for
president in the United States and the
California Democrat is trying to
position herself as a reformer who works
tirelessly to correct the abuses of the
criminal justice system but the senator
has one big problem her long record as a
Law & Order prosecutor Harris's new
memoir the truths we hold makes no
mention of her past as an old-school
drug warrior a defender of dirty
prosecutors and a political opportunist
who has made life more dangerous for sex
workers Harris doesn't apologize for her
previous stances even those she now
disavows instead she's decided to try
and convince voters that she has always
been a progressive prosecutor how do you
reconcile your contradictory past with
what you claim to support today I've
been consistent my whole career here are
some of the stories that the senator is
hoping you'll forget in the run-up to
2020 Harris's political rise has been
propelled by a years long high profile
campaign against alleged sex traffickers
what she's actually done is throw women
in jail for having consensual sex while
trampling on the rule of law to advance
her own political ambitions ignoring the
pleas of sex workers and human rights
advocates for over a decade she's fought
against campaigns to decriminalize
consensual adult prostitution in
California as Attorney General she
created a statewide program to get
truckers to report suspected sex workers
to police these policies didn't stop
traffickers but they did land plenty of
sex workers behind bars one of the
greatest defenders is backpage.com
Harris fought to destroy backpage.com a
classified site that sex workers used to
find and screen their clients even
though she publicly admitted that the
site's founders Michael Lacey and James
Larkin were protected from prosecution
under federal free speech laws but
tonight a groundbreaking arrest but a
month before Election Day in her Senate
race Harris went ahead and had them
arrested anyway parading them before the
cameras on pimping charges which were
then promptly dismissed by a judge when
Harris got to Congress she kept up her
crusade becoming a big proponent of the
2018 law known as cesta Fosca one
cannot cowardly sit behind a computer
committing their crime quite the
contrary
the result was that many sex workers had
no choice but to return to the streets
where soliciting clients is considerably
more dangerous because you don't know
who's gonna pick you up I throw that
there's more pension there's more guys
out here meanwhile Harris declined to
intervene in a real underage sex
trafficking scandal that involved dozens
of police and other local authorities in
the Bay Area America has a deep and dark
history of people using the power of the
prosecutor as an instrument of injustice
I knew this history well of innocent men
framed of prosecutors hiding information
that would exonerate defendants yes and
during her time as California's top cop
Harris contributed to that history
repeatedly by going to bat on behalf of
dirty prosecutors her office appealed
the dismissal of the case in which a
prosecutor had fabricated a confession
to secure a conviction and fought an
appeal in a case where a prosecutor had
lied to the jury during trial in 2015
Harris tried to stop the removal of the
Orange County District Attorney's Office
from a murder trial after it repeatedly
failed to turn over evidence to the
defense her office even tried to keep a
man in jail who had been wrongfully
incarcerated for 13 years after a judge
ruled that he had proven himself
innocent just because the man hadn't
delivered that proof quite fast enough
and as San Francisco DA Harris hid known
misconduct by a crime lab technician who
admitted to deliberately tainting
evidence did prosecutors working under
you know about the concerns about that
lab prosecutors which is what the judge
alleged did not know about it at least
said they did not know about it the
debacle has since led to the dismissal
of hundreds of criminal cases something
else it's past time we get done is
dismantling the failed war on drugs
starting with legalizing marijuana your
opponent Ron Golda said that he is for
the legalization of marijuana
recreationally your thoughts on that
I that he's entitled to his companion
Harris is a former drug warrior who is
now refashioning herself as
pro-legalization that's a positive shift
but not a reason to rewrite the past or
ignore the patterns it reveals in her
judgment four years after the cultural
tide had turned in favor of criminal
justice reforms Harris continued to
support la cama policies that
disproportionately hurt minorities as
California attorney general Harris
opposed marijuana legalization as latest
2014 promoted civil asset forfeiture
without a conviction as a way to fight
drug rings and sought to more
aggressively police prescription drug
use in her new book Harris reveals that
her drug warrior mentality hasn't
changed it's just that her emphasis has
shifted we also need to reinstate the
DA's authority to go after the major
pharmaceutical manufacturers and
distributors and we need to invest
resources in law enforcement efforts to
cut off the supply of fentanyl from
China let's believe in a more perfect
union
without mass incarceration of African
American men we put more people in
prison than any country on earth for no
good reason
yes we do and once these people were in
prison
Harris saw to it that they'd have a hell
of a time getting out I absolutely
believe there should be severe in
serious consequence for violent crime
which is why I have prosecuted those
cases and will always seek the highest
sentence as a prosecutor and law
enforcement I have a huge stick so I
decided I was going to start prosecuting
parents for truancy before her recent
about-face
Harris chose not to endorse proposed
sentencing reforms on the California
ballot in 2012 and 2014 and she defended
the constitutionality of cash bail until
2016 Harris's office also fought an
order to reduce California's prison
population after the Supreme Court
determined the conditions amounted to
cruel and unusual punishment although
she later claimed to be shocked by what
they had done
Harris's attorneys argued that
nonviolent offenders should stay behind
bars because the state needed the cheap
labor they provide we are part of a
longer story and we are responsible for
how our chapter gets written as she
blazes her path to the White House in
2020 Kamala Harris
is trying to rewrite her last chapter
but her record remains our children and
our grandchildren will ask at that
inflection moment where were you and
what did you do in service of your
family your neighborhood your community
and your country
[Music]